le procès de la ferme il a été reporté
pour des questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité posée par juan branco
l'avocat d'un des prévenus
elle concerne la définition du
harcèlement en ligne qui est reproché
aux accusés
s'il est question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité ne sont pas
transmises à la cour de cassation est
bien le procès reprendra le 21 et 22
juin pour deux jours d'audience alors
revenons à la ferme il a en janvier 2000
20000 a été victime d'insultés
homophobes et antifrançaises sur les
réseaux sociaux alors elle a répliqué
avec une vidéo instagram dans laquelle
elle tenait des propos insultant
vis-à-vis de l'islam cela lui a valu
cent mille messages de haine comme l'ont
rappelé aujourd'hui ses avocats des
insultes des menaces de mort de viol
alors elle a dû quitter son lycée
et puis toujours victime de harcèlement
elle a réitéré avec une seconde vidéo
dans laquelle elle tenait des propos
anti-islam
aujourd'hui elle vit reclus chez ses
parents ont l'écoutent je pense que tout
ce que j'aurais à dire et j'aurai encore
bien d'autres à venir pour l'instant je
me résume à ça c'est qu'il ya pas
d'anonymat que l'on soit jeune
adolescent en adulte à partir du moment
où on commet un crime sur internet on
peut être recherchée vous vous êtes
retrouvé et on peut être jugé devant un
tribunal
c'est pour ça qu'on est là aujourd'hui
et c'est à ce moment là que qu'il est
temps qu'il est temps de le réaliser
qu'il est temps de le dire la peur
change de camp
plus nombreux on sera à l'ouvrir plus on
sera forts plus on sera plus en face à
la menace et
et au harcèlement qui fera qu'empirer si
si on reste en rien faire si on continue
à se soumettre aujourd'hui treize
prévenus entre 18 et 35 ans était
convoqué au tribunal ils sont de toutes
confessions religieuses et la plupart
sans antécédent judiciaire
ils sont tous poursuivis pour
harcèlement moral en ligne pour cela il
encourt jusqu'à deux ans de prison et
30000 euros d'amendé et certains le sont
pour menace demain et ceux ci encourent
jusqu'à trois ans de prison et 45000
euros damende la suite possiblement le
21 juin